c'est du jamais vu dans l'histoire de la
vème république si l'inflation se
poursuit et même est plus élevé dans les
mois qui viennent je ne sais pas ce que
le gouvernement actuel pas proposé
[Musique]
alors cette indemnité en fait c'était un
chèque c'est un peu l'état père noël
l'état je dépense à tout va puisque
c'est un chèque de 100 euros qui doit
être distribuée à 38 millions de
français donc simple opération ça coûte
3 milliards 8 pour les finances
publiques on est sur un dispositif qui
est possible et on aura le même montant
qu'on perçoivent le rsa ou qu'on
perçoive 2000 euros net par mois par
exemple une infirmière surtout si elle
est libérale se déplace beaucoup en
voiture mais qui touche de 1100 euros
par mois n'est pas éligible à cette
indemnité inflation de même en
raisonnant ainsi on va aussi peut-être
tenir éloigné de la réforme un certain
nombre de familles monoparentales dont
on sait bien que les charges sont plus
importantes uniquement parce que le
parent qui a la charge du foyer va être
juste au dessus du seuil de 2000 euros
et enfin le dispositif tel qu'il est
prévu fait porter une charge lourde sur
les entreprises qui d'une part doivent
assumer la vence de trésorerie et aussi
des coûts de gestion importants
puisqu'il faut mettre à jour l'ensemble
du système de paye pour faire apparaître
cette ligne supplémentaire au titre de
l'indemnité en place unique
[Musique]
le sénat a voté un dispositif pour le
coup mieux ciblées et qui apporte une
aide plus importante aux bénéficiaires
coûte moins cher pour les finances
publiques le coût global du dispositif
et d'un milliard cinq les bénéficiaires
toucheront un chèque de 150 euros il
repose notamment sur une bonification de
la prime d'activité donc les
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux les
étudiants boursiers les invalides toutes
celles et ceux qui ont des bas salaires
qui rentre dans le revenu d'activité
seraient ou seront bénéficiaires de ces
150 euros en ciblant mieux on vise plus
juste on vise les familles raison pour
laquelle on a ciblé sur le revenu
d'activité
c'est à dire des personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui clairement identifiée c'est
entre 10 et 11 millions de personnes et
de foyers c'est plus avantageux parce
que des familles monoparentales jusqu'à
2300 euros vous êtes éligible et ça
commence pour les personnes seules à
1800 euros
[Musique]